Oh, hi, and welcome back.
In this class, we'll get an overview
of our agenda for the upcoming lessons,
as well as uncovering core concepts
of physically-based materials in the Unreal Engine world.
All right, let's go.
So as I just anticipated, in this class,
we'll explore real-time physically-based rendering,
or PBR, understanding what it is,
and some overall guidelines that could help
you use them more efficiently.
Next, we'll look at the differences between parent
materials and instance materials and expand their features.
This means we'll be reviewing parent materials and instance
materials and introducing the concept of the switch parameter
for instancing purposes.
We'll then be dialing it up with the development
of mass materials, reviewing how they're created.
And in this process, we'll be using minus nodes, clamps,
and linear interpolation, or lerp nodes, which I don't
think we'll actually explore yet.
And this magic lerp node will help us
with the creation of a mass material using one texture
and its RGB channels, which is going to be quite cool.
We'll conclude this course with material functions,
understanding what they are and how
to use function inputs to build an animated material function.
Then we'll check out how to use material
functions in parent materials.
I think we're ready to get started with some PBR theory.
So what is this real-time physically-based rendering
we've been mentioning since the beginning of class?
Physically-based rendering relies on a unified light
and shading system.
All right, but what does this mean?
It means that surfaces in real-time PBR
approximate how light behaves in the real world.
Physically-based materials tend to be more accurate
because they can be measured in lumens,
lux, inverse square law, energy conservation, et cetera,
et cetera.
And this approach tends to be more natural-looking
and is actually more intuitive and consistent.
So putting it down visually, the approximation
and unification of light and shade of TBRs
can be categorized into non-metallic and metallic
materials, as we can see in this slide.
Non-metallic surfaces are characterized
by their matte colors and absence of light reflectivity,
whereas metallic surfaces are highly reflective, as we know.
In these two charts on the left and right side
of the slide, you can see the RGB values
of real-life materials.
But take into consideration that the RGB
is actually a digital representation of color
using a finite set of numbers, right?
RGB is an additive color model,
which means we start with black, the absence of light,
and then add different amounts of red, green, and blue
to create a full spectrum of colors.
And here on the left, you can actually see
how different real-life materials like charcoal,
dry, dark earth, or asphalt are translated
to the digital world using this RGB system.
Keep in mind that in real life,
there are no full blacks nor whites,
and the color information of a surface always has a range.
And roughness is a fundamental factor
in the distinction between different materials.
It's going to define whether a surface is, for example,
made of metal, leather, or cloth.
And speaking about roughness,
remember that the specular input in a material
will define also its reflectivity.
So it's important to find the right balance
between the two, between roughness and specular,
even though for most non-metallic materials,
the default value of 0.5 specular
is usually physically correct.
Okay, so here you can find an overview
of the metallic range from 0 to 1.
And here, you can see a chart expanding
upon the 0 to 1 roughness range of a material,
defining how the light gets reflected on its surface.
And it can be a bit confusing
because it looks like the opposite of the metallic range
because a metallic value of 0
means that a material is not metallic at all,
while a metallic value of 1,
as on the right side of this chart,
means that a material is fully metallic,
while the roughness for it is opposite,
because a material with a roughness value of 1
has the light scattered in multiple directions,
making the material matte,
while smooth materials with a roughness value of 0
have the light bounced off at the same angle
in a single direction towards us,
creating a mirror-like surface.
All right, that was it for the theory of this class.
I hope you enjoyed it,
but you can find some additional documentation at this link
if you're interested in further expanding your knowledge
in physically-based rendering and materials.
Thanks for sticking around,
and in the upcoming lesson,
we'll look into parent and instance materials,
as well as the switch for our feature
to expand on those too.
All right, bye.